Oh beautiful
[Music]
in passions a therfore of freedom people
across the world
[Music]
marry
America God man thine every flaw confirm
my soul in self-control thy Liberty
Oh beautiful for Heroes proved in
liberating strife who more than self
their country loved and mercy more than
life
Amerika Amerika may God thy gold refine
till all success be nobleness and every
game
device
Oh beautiful for Patriot that seems
beyond dine alabaster cities undimmed by
human tears
Oh maketh AMERICA God shed His grace on
thee and Crown thy good with Brotherhood
from sea to shining sea from sea to
shining sea
[Music]
come go with me to that Lane come and go
with me to that man come and go with me
to that man where I am bound come and go
with me to that man
do that come and go with me to that land
where I am bound there's peace and
freedom in that land there's peace and
freedom in that land there's peace and
freedom
and where I'm bound there's peace and
freedom in there
nice piece
as Peace and Freedom one of that
hi everybody and welcome to GameSpot
live happy Valentine's yeah I'm Jessie I
haven't been on guess what live in a
minute this is Ben Jack you probably
know him we are gonna be playing far cry
new dawn today brought to you by far cry
new dawn I'm really excited I've been
pleased a week but yeah I'm really
enjoying this game it's it's uh it's a
very good time here may bring bring us
up a little bit more over there - there
we go yeah yeah how's it going I love
the sound of my own voice I don't know
about you Ben Janka oh we're about three
or four hours into the game so we've
been playing since Monday I don't know I
don't know when you started but uh yeah
we're about four four hours of the game
and we're starting off with part two so
you probably saw the stream yesterday is
you may not have but yeah what if you
want to check out the stream that we had
yesterday for more later but yeah join
us here we are at prosperity and this is
are you a male or a female character so
that should actually just shows grunts
I've got a guy that's sweet style going
nice dressed up like the famous Rex Colt
from Far Cry blood dragon because I
think it's my favorite far cry so I'm
really happy that I was able to get that
whole outfit going feeling feeling real
cool about it what's great but uh yeah
you look very threatening ah thank you
I'm super casual in my game so no one's
afraid for me I'm like in flannels and
whatnot but yeah you look great yeah
thank you I think I really like how the
scheme kind of leans into the more like
silly stuff which a big fan of silly
things oh yeah
big thanks to this is actually my first
far cry oh really yeah real tough but
I'm super enjoying it but I've been
running around the map and there were a
couple times where I would just get
eaten by animals and it's wild out there
man it's wild so I'm realizing now we do
have we invited you to the game and I
forgot that I I have to stay around you
so uh here I can just come on in with
the helicopter and I'm gonna
drop down really quick and you can just
you just jump on in oh absolutely
every option I wouldn't sabotage your
helicopter just yeah all right there we
go now we're on our way
yeah so we're playing co-op I don't play
co-op yet this is gonna be a fun time so
this is our our map we've got I've
already kind of worked my way through
the bottom I've actually taken a couple
of these yeah your base is at the bottom
so you're kind of working your way up
and you can when you take the the the
bases that the enemies have a really
cool thing is the actually you can
recycle them now because that's one of
the more fun parts for Far Cry at least
for me I think and I've been doing that
a couple of times it also gives you
certain gear sets if you kind of farm
them out so I've been doing that but
moving up north rescued a couple of
people we've got some more some more
folks so we can kind of pick up you
might recognize some of the names ratio
is Erin's favorite sidekick so we can we
can pick some of the stuff like on the
way let's we'll do a treasure mission
then we'll head up to get Horatio and
then we'll actually go to the story
mission that we have to do up here which
is the first mission in the second we
tell them what we're doing what our goal
is to fight a bear yes so there's I've
been told that there's a bear that we've
got to fight somewhere that helps us
unlock like a special ability but we've
got to get some story progression so I
think that's kind of our main our main
goal what we're going for but uh yes so
we're you know we're looking for this
bear that's the goal of the stream we're
playing until about 1:00 p.m. Pacific
time and the goal is to find this bear
so we can fight it together
yes but yeah I am joining Ben as it is
gun-for-hire so it's a good time I see
that you've got your grenade launcher
already out ready - I'm ready at all
times just in case I've got your back
I've got your back just kind of kind of
hang out and see what's going on we're
gonna fly over this first one I already
took this but it gets harder like they
take it back again and then you can go
back and you need to level up your
weapons and then try to take it back
again yeah they get more ethanol the RPG
elements are actually really like
hard-coded into a lot of the progression
in this game which I didn't expect
because I was like oh yeah you put
numbers over the guy's heads and there's
health bars that have like higher tiers
and stuff
but you actually have to like craft
weapons further up in tears to actually
like stand a chance against some of the
harder enemies so there's a weird like
actual sense of progression through
through making all these things like I
have all golden to your weapons right
now I've got some great blood dragon
throwbacks that I'm very into excellent
yeah because we're playing the deluxe
edition yeah good stuff yeah and if you
guys want to play this game it's coming
out tomorrow on Xbox one PC and ps4 and
we're playing on the ps4 version just
FYI and we're in the chat right now so
if you've got any questions or want to
talk about this game please do we're on
the YouTube chat youtube.com slash games
but if you're watching somewhere else on
this guy so keep you covered oh whatever
whatever you feel like is good so I've
got this it's really really cool
it's the blood dragon pistol that is got
a built-in silencer it's like a
three-round bursts it glows it's it's
very good I'm a big fan of it so the
first thing we're doing here is we're
hitting up this treasure treasure
mission yeah so we've got a treasure
hunt explain treasure hunts so treasure
hunts are kind of like these you go to
some of the places that you might
remember from the original Far Cry 5 and
Far Cry 5 kind of focused a lot on kind
of like doomsday preppers people getting
ready for sort of like whatever
apocalypse might be coming because it's
just a real thing for them and and a
real weird sick kind of sense of humor
none of them made it it seems so in the
midst of like make it so that they can
something to do I'm gonna kill that
snake so and have to find something for
them to do they ended up building like
booby traps or crazy ways to like lock
out their possessions so that people
couldn't get into them so now you go
into their places and you find out how
to solve those puzzles to get in and
braid their supplies basically so
they're kind of
kind of puzzle ideals love it I'm gonna
follow your lead so you just if you have
anything that you need me to do just let
me right now I'm gonna go back and I'm
gonna read this again because I please
do I'm gonna check out and see how the
chats doing right now how you guys doing
in the chat over on YouTube
if you're just joining us we're playing
for crying you don't and it comes out
tomorrow so there's a whole bunch of
gears and stuff scattered around here so
we've gotta find are we just collecting
so there might it might just be a
collection one there might not be
something kind of hidden away or it
might be that doesn't so friendly at all
oh god oh my god so wild life is in full
effect there we've got angry cats
explosions in the distance you got it
that was not something I was ready for
you never are prepared for that I like
how it kind of gives you the heads up
about oh here we go this is what we're
looking at so we've got this area down
here on this little Preppers area to
kind of hang out and I see some perk
points in there it's locked from inside
so I wonder if we've got to find a way
to crack that door open but I'm just
that's that's kind of the name of the
game because like I was saying that the
the progression kind of makes you want
to care about those crafting materials a
lot more because you have to keep making
more and more weapons it's all over the
place so I like that there's so many
things we don't have to worry about
looting that yeah I'm not playing on my
account so I'm just kind of testing
things out this is Aaron's account I
think that was the grenade launcher ooh
boy it works my gun works it definitely
does it might over work yeah I also have
a unicorn flamethrower that is so sick
yeah shooter shoots out some here hold
on just shoot it a little bit really
shoot my flame
my unicorn flame yeah so it's this is
also more of the we know the silly stuff
it shoots a multiple colored flame a
real magical sound like this is my main
weapon I cannot wait to use it I'm gonna
drain all oh you've also you've lit
everything on fire in the process of
showing off but that's kind of the whole
cool we might actually just move on from
this custom be honest
your boys real real not smart no it's
okay I'm getting all the components
getting nice stuff to build things with
it's fine terminal it's fine I set the
whole place on fire but it's fine oh
it's fine we're fine it's fine we're
fine I'm in the back I'm gonna watch out
for anything uh actually I think maybe
we should just let's just go to the
story mission actually okay so I'm gonna
sit here in this weird precarious
leaning forward position and then we're
just gonna head forward because I think
we might actually have quite a bit to
clear through to get to our goal of
hunting that that legendary bear so I'm
gonna hit that nice tron bow thank you
great flex that the rainbow flames are
appropriate for Valentine's Day yes yes
we planned this all along
100% calculated Bob dad said I feel like
Jesse might get been killed a lot no I'm
gonna help him as much as I can I'm just
gonna do nothing until he needs me to
I'm just gonna run around and collect
components and duct tape maybe she
thinks with my flamethrower if he needs
me to
that's all I'll try not to blow up any
more boards yeah uh next is a real spicy
way to start start everything off so as
fur as we're flying over to where we're
going you might kind of recognize some
of these these places like believe this
is the the
I'm kind of from the beginning ish
because we're coming up on the the
middle of the map but as you get out
here there's bridges things are
destroyed it's really interesting
actually how their take on the
apocalypse is the instead of being like
the dusty kind of bleak burnt up kind of
kind of outlook on it
it's everything got overgrown and it is
there's color and stuff I kind of like
it it's nice to look at grey fox that
fly over West Elizabeth whoa it's okay
plots happening plot I feel like plot
shouldn't have happened in the elevator
though or in the helicopter I think
we're upside down I don't like it it's
telling me to exit the vehicle did you
know she's gonna keep heading towards
the objective it's creeping me out man
yeah so uh so this is direct sequel to
Far Cry 5 yes right after it 17 years I
believe yeah and the people asking in
the chat you don't need for 35 to play
this game this is its own game it's a
standalone and I believe it's also not
it's not fully priced either it's like
it's technically so if you thought Far
Cry 5 looked interesting but you didn't
want to jump in for 460 right away I
like the silliness all I'm gonna play it
but I enjoying this game yeah yeah all
right so we're coming up on I don't
think I'm gonna bring us down real
slowly
real smooth yeah I'm happy that I didn't
I feel like I didn't really need to play
it in order to enjoy this game and play
this game like I feel fine just jumping
right into this
they do a good job of kind of catching
you up in the beginning - like Hobbit
there were these people that were
leading like a cult and then the bomb
happened that we can grew up and now
it's all over great that might change
now that we're like exploring this part
of the game where it refers back to the
last game yeah we're about to meet the
like yeah I wouldn't say is the
protagonist kazi's kind not he's the
mate I was like the Darth Vader he's the
focuses on him but it's not entirely
about him okay should I be armed or
should I be friendly yes I can you're
creeping me out man let me in me I'm not
gonna blow anything up I'm just gonna
stand behind you I'm just gonna protect
you keep the rocket launcher away I put
it away I can't be trusted
okay so maybe we got to uh heroes what's
going on in the map right now god ah
we've got to go over here now okay oh
there's our boy oh you know he's just
standing here listen oh so ominous i'ma
jump in this boat it's a cool dinghy I
just jump on up yeah I don't go
you have such a cool outfit yeah no uh
Rex Colt is an interesting character
yeah I'm real cool she got that that
full suit of armor going on which is
pretty cool too
the judge does look really cool come
back and gets you it's very impressive
that you're able to stay afloat should
be able to jump back up there might
actually be a seat you can kind of like
oh no no seats I'll just stand right
behind you and staring at you weirdly
actually it was really funny that was
staring at you really all right
so we just got to keep heading down this
river then and I think this is where
we're going
does this one have the map editor I
don't believe it does it's it's more of
like a kind of brought in kind of
concise you're getting kind of like the
coop Oh
hangout deal oh they're chasing us I'll
throw a knife at him when that doesn't
work I'm going to try to shoot backwards
shooting lets you fire
that's fine they can't catch us anyway
we're too quick see that Illuminati
brings up that that interesting
radiation zone good turn back now did he
tell us to go here maybe said go to
where it all ended
oh hi the boats here
no thank you there we go God got him
good job I'm gonna check the map again
here in a second odd that they're saying
that the the main character could be the
judge and that I'm into the scheme does
a good job of calling back - it's a 5 a
lot nice alright so where where where
are we going where is it Thomas it's
ahead - it's not see I think that's oh
it's here prophecy got this we're close
it's been it's been a bit
so pretty out here yeah today for a boat
ride
the constant aurora borealis entirely
localized our cry new dawn at this time
of year it's it's good to good to do it
oh there's some there's some some
nonsense happening up here we're gonna
drive right into it cuz that's what you
do that's how we get there head on over
this way you've already told us that sir
he's just really excited investigate the
beams Oh everything's all on me on it's
a good thing I brought all my my lights
on my guns and my outfits you've got
this cool blue glow to your weapon oh
there's a was a beam of light right over
here
getting close so this is all new stuff
to both you and I we haven't played this
far so we're experiencing it for the
first time it was like a house over here
that because what what better time to
loot than in the middle of an important
story mission here he is he found us
hello oh he disappeared I'll take it
what oh there's some I think we might
need to pull out your flamethrower
really quick and torch those leaves for
me okay I think there's a right here
super burned away he's tell us the
burning yeah yeah okay yeah got you it's
fine this is fine I didn't know leaves
wood would warm up like that but here we
are what we're in those leaves this is
these are the question Oh quite know
what's going on right now but all right
so we've got a I didn't die oh there's
another one off in the distance to
another beam oh whatever it is does
investigate the beams let's find the
next one all right
I feel like there's like a like a sight
puzzle with that or something but we'll
probably have to come back to it after
we get something else because it gave us
that piece from from interacting with
that there's another one way over this
way let's go to that one be asking chat
this is just co-op we're not playing a
multiplayer thing right now and we're
playing for crying you doing on the ps4
bob says it was the perilous two
apparels there that of course there were
those leaves yes only only cause who
dies nice dev thank you ah oh boy he's
back yeah there he is
what say we got another part of the
symbol so I'm gonna want to punch this
punch this punch things there's a
there's a sound that was me yeah it's
all like sight puzzles going on okay so
I see I see that so we solved that one
saw us to move on to we burned the first
one when I punched the second sometimes
she just kind of is percussive
maintenance when does this come out
tomorrow or on ps4 Xbox one PC it's
still marked I wonder why it's cuz
investigate all of them I think we need
to it's behind us yeah I'm gonna go in
the other direction it's pointing
pointing to that one again I don't know
if maybe there might be more that we
have to
I'm gonna go back to because it's
marking it yeah okay I'm here again
inside search soon I'm wondering if we
have to line it up like there's there's
something we have to do once we clear
out the rubble to make it work do
something oh you're like throwing
throwing things am I supposed to do that
to all this
maybe I'm just gonna keep punching
things oh this literally is he's telling
us to break it all okay I'll use a
weapon my fists do nothing
oh we already did destroy it oh here it
is I see it it's right there oh I see it
but do I have to like pull out the
puzzle piece of a very simple way to
look at it I can see it just take some
pills really quick but I think that the
piece that we pick up we have to somehow
pull out to put it in the place that
it's missing the extra point so I need
to figure out how to switch to that if
it's a thing I can pull out or is there
something I have to like the marker
stops here so these are these are the
puzzles yeah
box I wants to know how do you play the
guy from Blood Dragon so you get the the
armor pieces by clearing out one of the
one of the actual camps and from that
you get different parts of it
maybe I just have to like stare at it
maybe I have to like it looks like all
the parts could be there except it's
missing the two ones I'm pretty sure you
have to do that's Brock
I'm priestly because you come up and you
take the piece from him and then you you
knock the stuff away and then you have
to complete it with part that you picked
up gray fox said Ben yes use puzzle
piece yep how do I pull it out how do I
do this puzzle pullout piece
oh it's not the throwables it's not over
there is it around here um maybe we can
come back to that I'm gonna go try the
other one and see if maybe maybe you
have to like collect all the pieces
before you can do it okay we get stuck
on these rocks again they weren't ready
for
we got ahead of ourselves before okay so
now I got the piece actually pop you got
it he pulled it out okay so I think I
have to stand somewhere here oh hold up
to draw it out there we go I've got to
stand back here next to the light okay
this is all starting to make sense so
we've already got that done need to
it's not pulling it out maybe I got like
or have we not burned away everything is
that what I flew up man that's true it
is missing a piece yeah there's nothing
else here to burn
it's telling me to hold up but I can't
draw it out if I hold up your try
holding up on the d-pad really quick for
you okay here anywhere okay okay I'm
doing it I'm a time there dude I'm here
for you
[Music]
look to the cross find your answers
puzzles man
why can't I pull it out that's well here
now that I know that that's the button
to pull pull the thing I'm gonna go to
the other one now and see if that one
[ __ ] cuz I'm a feeling I might confuse
something and it thinks I'm trying to
solve two things at once or you'll run
to the one that's very far away Fox said
can you access a piece you grabbed from
your inventory so his aim hold up to do
it and it wasn't happening
I mean worst case we can restore
attention we can also do a different
mission
can we there is another story one that I
have for a Fight Club which is pretty
excitable
so this hold it out again uh-huh and
there we go so that's how it's supposed
to work okay you did it so it is a
sightline puzzle it's just I I pushed
the game in the wrong direction so you
got that one and now would go back to
the other one and see if it lets me do
it okay
it wasn't letting it yeah because we
lived wrong we didn't solve the first
puzzle before we went to the second
puzzle
we got it guys we're solving we're
solving the puzzles together reflux at
worst case use a gameshark all right
it's true no Potter our game genies we
got to make this this happen okay so I'm
run over here jump up on this dock we'll
make a heroic leap over to the other
part of the dog into it and then this'll
come in there we go so it's for solving
puzzles yourself a puzzle we're making
it happen all necks are all the take
downs like Far Cry 5 there are a couple
of newer ones I think are ones I don't
think I've seen it's still very fun to
do them so we're running through the
woods if we will have another puzzle to
solve
I feel like we will it's all telling us
to investigate games
we got some some pink fires up here
pink fire pretty far cry 2 was fantastic
it still holds up really well the day -
we're close there he is
get that piece there's that boy give us
the piece got it it's up here oh it is a
choice he's gotta like doing these oh I
see yeah from here
this isn't see if there's some missing
oh we've got a spin the the thing in the
background okay go find a way he's been
that thing it's been okay which maybe
it's connected to something it's so
there's a pulley on the porch all right
so we need to spin it I think this might
be it yeah yeah wait there we go yeah
got it yes no good so good so good at
puzzles
he's got a bow I like how everything's
pink for Valentine's Day
yeah it's it's all hand appropriately
liam says that this is your first fire
crying you've I've been having a good
time with it you definitely try five
yeah I think I will it's this is very
similar to it yeah far cry 5 is a good
time there's a lot of it'll be
interesting too because you'll be going
from knowing these characters when
they're older it should be like a
prequel yeah yeah yeah yeah so far cry 5
had made some changes to its formula
like what did you think of what do you
think were the best improvements that it
made to the Far Cry series uh I think
that one of the best things far cry 5
did was and they're very aware of it
which was fantastic cuz right at the
beginning they make you climb a tower
and they're like all right you don't
have to do this anymore
that that'd be silly if you had to climb
towers a whole bunch to like find things
and just kind of making their their
open-world structure kind of flow a lot
better I also like the structure where
hello
there's the bomb whoa I like the
structure where you start off in the
middle and you can go in any one of
three directions it feels pretty good
and also I like to silly this animals
everywhere we're in a bunker now
I thought Oh God who's here someone here
I kicked a small animal and it pops up
into my face it's a rat I was not
prepared for oh hi
take the book it's the death note oh no
not the death know it be careful we got
here
can't think I'm getting hungry topside
but I'm terrified I did the right thing
I want to do the right thing right now
dang so that the other cool thing is
they do a really good job of
environmental storytelling in this game
because a lot of the people are gone
because it's a post-apocalyptic so you
get to see like I'm guessing this is
Joseph's room well with all the counting
the days apparently someone spent a lot
of time down here oh and apparently the
measure is in weeks not days possibly so
how much you want to bet he had a pretty
rough time as anyone would spending that
much time down here oh there's another
note girl joseph.thiery
he said he heard a voice
I produced a fasting and prayer I've
heard the voice again and I have seen
what is to come in the face of the one
who will Shepherd Eden when I am gone it
was not a face I recognized it did not
look like me so it is not my child of
blood but they will be child just as all
are my children
I will leave my word here when I go and
when it is return to Eden that is when
we will manifest our destiny God has not
shown me what that will be
whoa what is happening I what is
happening I progressed I walked outside
and everything turned I was just trying
to read his journal Oh God not showing
me what that will be but I have faith in
it and it will be it will be what is
right the prophecy completed we did it
and we're moving on hi glue I'm with you
I was curious if like going down here
change anything was just the same deal
alright looking for food so now we get
to go back up here probably in the
lettuce in or do you want to go check
out that Fight Club that's done you said
Fight Club and I want to hear more about
the Fight Club yeah see it maybe not
being in here but I would like to
witness it it's the first rule screwed
up yeah I like when games do really
really cool puzzles like ok I didn't
expect that far cry would make me do
sight line puzzles yeah that that was
the first of those in this game and take
some of these plants but we're in part
two of the game so if you missed out on
part one there's there's footage all
over the internet and GameSpot that's a
big fish oh and if you're just tuning in
we're playing Far Cry new dawn brought
to you by Far Cry new dawn and it's out
tomorrow on Xbox one ps4 and PC
for 39.99 yeah here we go I'm trying to
find a boat because it's across the way
and I know if we want to make that swim
oh just smack you in the side oh yeah
this is what the heck is this probably a
good call maybe I can call the boat from
over there it's worth checking out
just stay here uh you come with me yeah
this looks like a place where you can
call a boat up it's a nice day first my
god it's so sunny there's so many fish
fish location discover grim docks
they don't look grim to me yeah it's
kind of a over yeah yeah they need a
paint job but they're not girly XS yeah
we we got access to the game a little
bit early so we could prepare coverage
in our stream looted some stuff anything
else I don't think we can actually call
boat from here which is weird there's
backpacks throw a lot of backpacks
there's a canoe over there I don't think
we can actually drive the canoes
that's I'm looking for I got one more
one more components to grab in this
place be wrapped up as I said it let's
both of us collect there's a bag in the
tree I get it I got my tree oh I don't
have a gun yeah I can I can shoot it
down that is appropriate for this it
don't feel like I should set that on
fire or use it grenade thank you
yeah yeah let's wanted an excuse to
shoot my I am a My Blood Dragon bow
vii we haven't done a lot of our
fighting gap which I'll get my compound
I got I got all these cool weapons with
these makeshift silencers and stuff
that's cool yeah we can't use this boat
I think it's a proper I'm just gonna you
know what let's just swim it
you have my robot arm and swim it out
this also lets me look over and talk to
people because I can just hold forward
there you go how's the chat doing oh you
guys want to talk to us
we're on the YouTube chat right now you
shoot back on such games back yeah how's
everyone's day going happy Valentine's
Day what are you guys doing for
Valentine's yeah well you're pointing
tomorrow heck yeah getting that dark
chocolate yeah Oh what is biting me oh
oh it's a big fish I was in his way it's
fine it's weren't too quick for these
fish to catch me I'm in heavy armor and
that fish is keeps biting me horseman
moose over here what happens when use
the clip they were on the water I can't
use it right now it's not letting me
yeah when we get out on the other end
you can try that out and see what
happens
you probably slept those fish behind you
Bob Jones wants to know our blood
dragons in the game I haven't seen any
blood dragons yet but said my my
favorites you there's so many fish
around you
he keeps by oh gone thank you I was a
real jerk oh no I got you huh okay oh no
I didn't get you I got them good I
killed that fish everything's fine
wrestled oh my god his friend is back
his most pissed off ID I'm dying it's
okay this is fine I'm on my way
oh wow no I can't even know you ready to
spawn in 19 seconds it's fine okay
that's fine I got I got some cool arrow
shot yes multi-player I know this co-op
Alex that I'm doing here hey what's up
and welcome plant for crane you're doing
what the what is happening oh oh is this
the bear fight I don't know I don't
think that's the bear fight these guys
did all the work for me
excuse me yeah but they're also bad guys
okay yeah
Oh their friend Hank dead yet I shot him
yeah okay we're good grab that Ludum
there's another bear around here oh no
God found him whoa yikes I don't know I
hope not
and we feel real bad about what I just
did it's got so angry so quick stuff
yeah make things can you swim upside
down I don't think so I'd like to be
able to swim upside down though that's
the the freedom that I'm looking for in
my my video game get that perfect bear
pal oh wait a minute am I looking out
here we're getting Buddhist
[Music]
shoot it that's that works got my on my
bat back full skin and see have to med
kit I know I'm gonna need it
oh yeah you're smart I'm gonna crap some
buckets to cuz animals have been biting
me left and right
it's the animals make me believe the
fish brought me down there it was fish
they're very big I've got a bear
I shot multiple bears but the fish got
me cuz I was in water I can't take my
gun out in the water there's a supply
drop coming in somewhere - lets get that
ethanol here wait for it to show up on
the map oh where did you come from don't
do it the Bears everywhere he's down
Yeah right it's it's like I I knew it
was coming
feel that I feel like gray fox it's got
that that Pelt life going on oh that's
the yellow that's the Fight Club guy
we're gonna give it a go are you
I mean hey I'm down kind of far cry is
this this is a it's a direct
continuation of far cry 5 yeah happening
many years in the future after a bomb
goes off and they after all rebuilds
they people have been hiding in bunkers
and then they all have to rebuild but
wildlife has flourished and the trees
are growing again yeah I think we got
some twins in common right yeah a while
back
I'm like the right-hand man they're
talking about the leaders of the highway
no financial trouble and the
post-apocalypse yeah why can't just
trading bottle caps or whatever whatever
you want to move first I need to know
using asked us to punch him broke it all
right cool I'm down a joint Fight Club
let me do the punch where is it should
be right there
am i strong enough for Fight Club he
said he broke it I don't know about this
or maybe I have to do it because I maybe
oh there we go yeah you're way stronger
than me so I'm not always stronger when
everybody got some strong enough nice oh
you're in Fight Club congratulations I'm
two weapons I like my weapons how about
you stash your weapons and I hold on to
my weapon all right
he didn't ask me yes you true I also got
you back seventeen guys in a row this
guy's powerful it took my weapons - yeah
when you stashed it just - mine too
that's why we're gonna get into a big
fist fight down here in the sewers I'm
ready to back you up some real real
scrappy teenage Ninja Turtle stuff I'm
into it Yeah right
Oh going over here go in here your
people sure crowd
excuse me I'm not gonna fight a child
show us in angry boys I hope this
allowed this is not allowed I'm so glad
this kids he works for Fight Club though
and that's a problem okay yeah sure was
a lot of yelling they pick on you
lollipop
I don't like any of this actually
missiles into this you know what these
people are so angry outside what you do
that dog all right we gotta kick their
butts yeah that dog looks like he's in
bad shape
we gotta save him won't stand for it I
will not stand for it
drats saying seventeen guys the records
37
gasps he's all talk huh he's gonna steal
all my weapons I hope where I'm going I
don't need med kits
oh and wait are we fighting dogs funny
I'm so scared I'm gonna stand by your
side I'm ready
oh this looks proper bad oh there's Mike
it's everywhere
that's nice when I collect some actually
you should get some you should get the
med kit wait wait I'm gonna pick up that
stick - good call there's another med
kit here - all right I'm just gonna
punch things cuz I can't find a stick
you keep that stick I think you've got
some pretty good punching power tubes
you got a turns account
oh my god it's aw oh my god this is Owen
that's terrible
I'm not a fan of that I'm here to fight
people not dogs oh we got here is music
Sam it's dead now
well he has a baseball bat if you pick
it up yeah yeah oh it's not a dog yeah
yeah I do not like yeah oh there's so
many there's so many more boys
[Applause]
I do like that you can throw boring or
six is good health gets if you want to
pick one up what's the goal guy asked us
to do it he's gonna help us take care of
the two of the two bad guys this is good
fur for getting your nails done well you
got a metal pipes seen it shoot oh hello
excuse me my back
[Applause]
survive the second round and do is he's
got a friend now it's not so bad oh gosh
oh I'm gonna take this definitely come
here you let's go yeah right
we were just solving puzzles like a few
minutes ago and now we're gonna fight I
was literally saying oh we haven't done
any fighting yet this is wild
oh no help me all right there we go I'm
worried about that explosive barrel in
the middle oh yeah I don't know what its
deal is just don't hit it oh no there's
fire this fire Oh why we can't fight
fire oh this is bad
ooh nailed it man was taking through my
own lane I broke his glasses heck yeah
oh I'm on fire so much fire everywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
boys down excuse I'm clinging to life
come on I got you survive thank you
Oh got smacks you good yeah
[Applause]
just through my bad Adam as a last ditch
effort someone still here I'll try to
find more of these both of pipes very
good best weapon so far in this pit now
we're in this really announcer he's
annoying here's hoping there's a guy up
there with is that actually who were
fighting get down here that is an orange
guy is the one he's got a shield - oh
yeah oh boy keep stunning him yeah yeah
yes yeah yeah yeah man that just you kid
it just to do anything yes he didn't do
anything for that good look I got his
spiked back
I like it I kneel before the crowd it's
me kneel okay am i kneeling I think we
are watching
[Applause]
Wow this took a turn yes dream really
took a turn but I'm into it who was he
the last fight I see was it shot I think
he was yeah we worked him I'm cool just
spiked bad I'm gonna hold on to it
because they took my weapons and I don't
know if I'm gonna get it back yeah
back into the sewer we go where we
belong
basically I really like this art still
you guys are just tuning in we're
playing far cry new dawn yeah we were
solving puzzles and now we were in the
fight club and now we just left I think
we won should we get money we'll find
out
hi emo how you doing see you see you
just say your name say your name say
your name yeah ray headed back to the
guy yeah I'm going back up to the guy
that's where we got to go so the
question about the lower price point it
is the map is a bit smaller but I feel
like a lot it's a lot more dense there's
more stuff to do and there is a lot to
do you telling me yeah I spent like two
days in part one just cuz there was so
much I could do yeah dang this guy's a
real card where's our money where my
guns event oh okay Auto said hi from
Turkey hello hello thanks for joining us
back yeah gave me those weapons yeah I
got it back thank you
success attainment hey okay now that's
what I call entertainment oh and he left
us like a car so we can get out of here
to go to our next place let's go got
some jams
this is good here I'm gonna have jams
see do we want to go back up here and
see what's going on with the story
towards bear so I think we got to do
this to get to their stuff let's see
what them yeah trying to drive out that
way
[Music]
Oh bad guys coming that's fine we passed
them too too quick form 2 fast 2 furious
in the UK hekia come on over there
thanks for joining us thanks for spend
your evening with us yeah I hope you're
all having a good day wherever you are
good time hanging out playing far cry
[Music]
we're put on ps4 but you can also play
on Xbox one or piece of it I'm so happy
that I can dress my character up like
Rex that's pretty cool that's really
important to me there's constantly all
over the place this time of year tirely
localized in this video game it's more
likely than you might think I have the
arm from Fudd yeah it's I have the whole
the whole outfit for the main character
from Blood Dragon out and I also have
the deluxe edition it's actually just in
the regular yeah so I believe the deluxe
edition gives you quick access to it but
you can actually earn it in the game
which is how I did it
shellye not shoot'em if you want it I'll
leave it up to you oh that's person no I
thought they were bad I swear I'm not a
bad person
it's dark I don't know what was going on
[Music]
dang are your much better driver than I
am I've had a fair amount of practice
I'm always driving into trees so that's
when you know you're having the most fun
though because you're not on the road
yeah I really like the the radio
stations in the game well they give you
two options so you get this kind of like
old bully station you also get the the
more like current kind of hip hop setup
the music that yeah but I'm a hundred
percent into the the older do they have
new guns
yeah at the beginning they're introduced
to this really cool saw thing mmm-hmm
you probably pull that out at some point
but all the weapons are kind of like
makeshift kind of thrown together deals
we can we can move to show off some of
them for me when we get out of the car
up here we're only a hundred meters away
from our destination
I'm gonna crash down hit the water too
hard
that's alright we don't need that so as
you can see we've got like it's like a
famas but with a whole bunch of like
garbage bags for a silencer like ice
past 12 with the can launcher I've got
my Far Cry bow or my Blood Dragon bow I
mean yeah I also have the the pistol
from Blood Dragon as my my main choice
there's some good weapons and you've
also got that that flamethrower I'll
just take it out
she's got it's got some some cool cool
unicorn aesthetics going on but just
give it a little little beautiful so
good oh no I set it on fire
it's fine if we get her the cutscene do
their won't even know yes good all right
now we're progressing in the story I've
got the book the Death Note
it's here I've got the Death Note Let Me
In and then I'll eat this potato chip
come on in thank you oh thank you how
the the theory is that that person I
play is the main character from five oh
really yeah is that the theory that's
the theory okay can we ask him hey hey
are you that guy I know through they've
got a lot of lot of words that they do
now he hasn't talked at all he's just
but he has polite gestures and I'm okay
with that
let's see your character here I can I
can show them off really quick while
we're in the middle of running so my
character looking looking real good
I don't have the eyepiece on because I
feel like the aviators are probably a
Vieira's go with the outfit so I've been
I've been doing that I've also got
hidden in the game somewhere you can
check out our video in our gameplay
channel the yes you can actually get Sam
Fisher sneaking so where you gonna find
it the only one way to find out you're
getting too far from the judge I messed
up failed I got too busy because I want
to show off that's okay it's final
restart we're good
I just got excited about showing some
cool things yeah that was for you I took
a mission fail for you
Oh G J star don't say I didn't do
anything cool for you because I just
hope you enjoyed it
we're gonna be playing for another half
hour we're playing co-op right now and
this is Far Cry new dawn
he does look like the guy from field one
the jacket please yeah you guys are
right
person with the bucket what is this when
it out pour one out for the homies that
they lost follow the judge does this I
Jim know this is gamespot.com welcome to
gamespot.com
James spot in 50 words Tube Cobb slash
GameSpot hey what's up chickens oh wow
that actually worked
I will go inside of the church what is
inside of the church
I bet it's Joseph's probably I'm willing
to bet well we've got the death note so
it's true that's what he wants or it hmm
pictures this is not Joseph this is also
not what I was expecting
oh cool Pelt well that's the son huh it
might be do you have the book yes I have
the definitely yes yes I wrote your name
oh yes I've inherited uh-oh are we the
rulers well I guess I was it to us it
should have been me well you should have
looked for the books just sitting there
you could have just gone there which are
really bad at finding books he looks
like he's so mad yeah
he's trying to relax we just found it
for him if you want to take credit we
literally don't care we can just move on
yeah you just say you found you can take
the credit our family still believes in
him and they'll never stop believing in
him until they understand that he was
not a messiah he was just a man we're
all just men yeah anyway you think
anyway I'll see you later why don't you
take the credit
we're easily gonna move on our way we're
trying to find a bear I didn't want to
get involved in this don't do that you
know he's really intense no I don't feel
like doing that today all right cool
okay thanks for the blood also you're
intense and it's time for us to leave
does this guy even lift that's a good
question yeah it's just a book that's
right all right even I don't ever want
to see him again
look at that sure don't hurt it it's
beautiful it's so thick there's so much
wool so much dang all right what's next
this is our crafting table I need some
ammo I would probably check what
checking out one when we get out of here
you do that let me see if I can look
around I neither maybe his hobby was
collecting books and that's why he's
frustrated he could've just went there
himself it was really easy we didn't do
any there was a band of chosen there
they will help you okay cool thanks for
the info
let's get on out of here it's kind of
kind of creeps me out a bit
yeah well back mostly just that guy not
before I take the gears though yep
I'm gonna take some too don't make it go
where is a crafting table I don't think
the oath if you have one yeah bummer
that's okay yeah someone asked to see
the map oh yeah your rule so I got a
mark where we're going next anyway so
the the map is kind of like this it's
called zoom out all the way it's not the
full map from 5:00 but it's it's a good
portion of it you kind of instead of
having like a 1:1 spot that you kind of
start off with and can branch out from
and kind of let you have had this you
start at the bottom and you work your
way up slowly but it works up pretty oh
I don't need to mark anything it's
alright show me where to go oh there's
another car perfect
this isn't my car but ol jams
this is a is my favorite part for
crappie in between the shooting where
you get to sit there and think and
reflect on everything while you listen
to cool jams on the radio yeah
[Music]
and we are playing for our new Don if
you just tuned in it's out tomorrow on
ps4 Xbox one and PC for $39.99 and this
is about I guess where five hours in
maybe five or six I spent a little bit
more time also running around gathering
yeah materials you boys got to make sure
he's good to craft all the the latest
weapons you gotta keep crafting just
collect everything you see as soon as I
saw that that blood dragon stuff though
I knew that that's the first thing I
wanted to build I don't know where the
song is so I'm too afraid to jump in and
yell tequila because I might just be
yelling - fela randomly we can yell it's
next to anything see these
I think these might be the best gyms in
a far cry game to outside of m.i.a in
three I ruined it make sure we're going
the right way
I talk about Oh Fran said favorite
animal in the game
that she was pretty bad I liked the dog
pal again yeah he's very useful it's a
good boy
yikes
yeah
Oh God take some pills really quick you
take em while you're driving yeah
[Music]
and get some sweet drifts coming around
these these hills think I just ran over
an animal not gonna think about it we've
got some some roads ahead
but what if the Rory hiromi-chan like
radio station that's what we really need
especially for ya oh no he was a good
guy it's you know there's only so much
you can really do and trying to drive on
this road don't don't drive like me yes
it's real a real chaotic situation yeah
Supply Drop detected you trying to find
that Supply Drop I'm not trying to hit
them I swear I'm trying to get around
them please we're trying to find the
Supply Drop
wipe out same somewhere right here sigh
see it is it is like dropping on top of
us huh oh no it's over there okay let's
get it this is when the driving gets fun
because you don't have to pay attention
to the road so does it can you still
fish yes I have my fishing pole it's
still there still relaxing still a good
time it was a bad guy behind this I'm
ready for him where are you he's got
pals I'm gonna bandage myself really
fast this loot Leutnant
what years a safe place it's 17 years
after the first game 35 4 farcry 5 first
Jack harbors back he's really uh-huh
what happened to Jack Harbor though
that's what we are we're where's my jet
Carver I fed I'll mock Far Cry new dawn
[Music]
like I'm pool that we got Rex Colt put
gimme gimme Jack Carver drive back up
here we'll go to the next part of this
mission hope this is the right
right way for this this is a very small
got a question who was your favorite and
Casey character from Parker I thought oh
I feel like like a real good easy go to
answer it is her I actually you know
what I like Nick Nick might be my
favorite because he's a real good dude
and he likes planes we're playing for
it's probably a lot quicker if we just
walked it but you know you can't hear
the radio when you watch this is a good
solution yeah so what you missed from
part one that we didn't show you can
check out on GameSpot but just clearing
out outposts and stuff and helping
prosperity to upgrade the UM your home
base I saw the bottom my forehead well
that's okay I'm really good at that too
I accidentally hit a few things on the
way here actually coming in stealth it's
probably the bow I already have a bow
thank you
it's neon colored and not ostentatious
at all
it's pretty cool take the bow from the
phone oh wait no I'm not leaving that
absolutely not you know keep the flame
thrower for and whenever we go you're
you're good to just keep and you got I
think full of arrows no no that's great
yeah yeah yeah full up let's go
cool compound though music does make
most things better Austin
oh these are bad guys what up it's me
I'm here to steal your stuff we're all
stoked about this the sneaking mission
always taking these guys out I think we
can either good or bad hold I'm gonna
try something really quick this is a bad
guy yep nice
I've got those those original jams
coming in now for permission all they
left another bow with some more arrows
[Music]
hey we're still sell everything still
selfie it's still stealthy
we're not stealthy no more that's right
this is good this is fine this is good
this is good
let's sounds like it's time for the
flamethrower to join the magic sound is
really what brings that thing that it
really makes it looks like a thing
you've got a light does should I light
it maybe it's up there secure the statue
area gonna climb up
I'm gonna shoot that man those oh my god
there's a lot of them
let me just miss about half my shots
good that's good
I can get it out there we go I'm down
well there are a lot of boys back here
cover me
should probably hear myself
oh we're pals guy yeah thanks thanks pal
nice
hello Yello got him now we get a little
bit of shoot we had the melee combat
before our getting the shooting you get
puzzle-solving bars up fire spreading
that wasn't me this time I swear unless
it was me earlier the fire from before
is just rejoice possible talk to the
leader okay there's like 20 people no
one could take out 20 people I can't
wait to play I'm so jelly soon yeah it's
not that far bring a friend it's it's
actually a lot of fun enjoying this grab
these uh these gear parts real fast yeah
I guess we got to go down into the water
[Music]
so stoked about this scary cave drain
the water all right so we've got to find
the valves and I think that's how we'll
drain it out that's not
that's not a valve I'm not sure where
you went I'm just I think on the other
side oh so there's like shoot that so
back up at the top there's that I can't
even go into oh hello
there's a passageway ah drain the water
I found it I'm proud of you
I can't even need me no sit when I I do
a dumb thing and I get down I can count
on you to get it to bring it back you're
killing a whole bunch of dudes before it
says a good time
destroy the pipes hello mutant fish I'm
not ready for that just kick out all
that wood down with one hit oh this is
got one of the pipes you got here that's
that's dangerous so the the pipes have
some not good okay I'm also down I think
up behind you yeah up on that thing yeah
yeah yeah I got that that sweet sweet
jump technology oh you did you fell off
look look up really quick Oh jump up
there yeah there's a bad gas yeah there
we go
Oh
Oh No so the that gases it's real
dangerous dangerous yes all right we've
got about seven minutes left in the
stream we died because of gas you know
you never nuts sometimes it's animals
sometimes it's guests it's it's a real
issue that should be acknowledged all
right so we can yeah Oh a check mark or
a check pointed the last one okay good
that's good let's run over here and do
this one
get out of there really fast I won't get
got this time stay far behind you and
revive you if you need it all right and
I think the other one might be down oh I
guess it's creeping anywhere around here
so we went down that way we've got that
one I find a third one thing I thought
that was how I drink all the water might
be in here around here yeah yeah ah this
might be it
break it down yeah I like all the the
colors in this too like the pink all
over everything so it's a it's a good
look all right so I think we're good to
climb up and out go away climb mountains
excuse me oh there's actually a way
that's designated for climbing over here
of course it's trying to climb the side
of the mountain like a like a dummy
ignite it I got just the thing I don't
think I want to do that there's a lot of
gas down there it's okay this is fine
this is what we're supposed to do okay
did I miss
oh no I didn't miss I definitely didn't
miss you did it all right we should run
you're probably probably we can probably
clear out okay guys heads up you don't
want to be here oh thank you Thanks Oh
sugar returning I don't want to talk to
Ethan was a real spicy boy Oh
the Cougars here oh no he followed me
I'm so sorry
oh my god
get him almost there we go yeah
they're gonna be upset gonna be upset
those are the leaders of the highwayman
you take that to the bank they will
definitely be upset all right where you
think I'm gonna head towards we might
have enough time to check in about five
minutes five minutes shoo
should we go back to the home base or
something oh we do what do you want to
show them what it is we took a base over
we do a hard version of a base whatever
you wanna do I'm gonna fast travel to it
we can get ammo and stuff and then we'll
see if we can take it over it'll be like
a one attempt kind of thing because it's
very difficult I barely managed to
scrape by but also for for anyone
wanting to do it this is the one you've
got a farm out to get all of the Blood
Dragon outfit so you know where to go
because as a person who also loves Blood
Dragon I feel like that that matters so
I'm gonna buy some ammo really quick and
uh let me know when you are gonna sell
this stuff - I got my flamethrower I got
my compound bow my m16 and my rocket
launcher I'm ready for this fight ready
scrap it we're gonna set up outside the
place we have to break our way in
got it you playing after 20 minutes we
wish we could but there are so many
things that we have to do this week
still tons of games are coming out and I
would like to do that that is a big part
of it so yeah yeah we'd love to say
break our way in here this is plus 150
oh did we already win so you get 150 for
scrapping it and then more for taking it
back okay so we've got a bunch of bad
bad boys around here oh yeah we can try
to stealth this but we are not gonna
work once we take out one yeah the rest
are gonna no I'm gonna no I'm gonna try
to run down here and see if I can take
out one of the one of the should be a
control for one of the alarms down here
somewhere okay
damn Topham I'm kind of moving around
towards the zipline remaining um never
mind I got seen alright coming notes
it's a real heist now oh boy heck yeah
[Music]
boy yeah this is real real spicy already
I also like to hide out in the buildings
because they don't go in there too often
there's one of the gold guys here got it
oh my god that guy's turbo dead now yeah
where do you get down down oh right
there was a badger look at me
revived I got you this this gun is has a
lot of kickback oh yeah now is the
perfect time for that flamethrower this
is this is the moment you've been
waiting for all stream
I was another guy whose ears are a lot
easier when you have great weapons to
fight them Oh on top of a car that just
rolled in with them yeah oh that wasn't
uh that was our help
I killed one over one of our friends Oh
pick the shield up that magic sound is
is everything it is I really love this
guy
so you've also brought a shield your gun
is nothing compared to my gun it's a
good question I think we've got some
people coming in here they are Hyrum
we'll throw so I'm gonna mark yes yes
well that feels good all right this was
war coming this way so there should be a
helicopter at some point but yeah yep
they're above us is people parachuting
in oh geez
it's real real player unknowns
battleground situation get him out of
here
we did it we did it that was a ban at
all that was yeah and uh so so fresh so
clean oh one o'clock Wow look at that
timing perf liberated the watering so
the watering hole is the one you want to
do if you want to get the blood dragon
stuff I highly recommend it one of my
favorite outfits in the game yep
or sure yeah alright let's close this
thing out
yeah yeah so thank you guys for joining
us if you guys want to play Far Cry new
dawn it's coming out tomorrow Xbox one
PC ps4 it's 39.99 thanks for joining us
on GameSpot live and thanks for variety
the game far cry new dawn thanks guys
and we'll see you next time see you
later take it easy everybody see you
tomorrow
[Music]